foreign the Bell Tolls for the 158
people who perished in October in one of
the worst accidents in South Korea's
recent history
families and relatives gathered at this
Buddhist temple in Seoul to remember
those they lost
words from bereaved family members are
read out
I miss you more with the passing of time
with every breath each of my joints
cries out you worked hard toward your
dream of having your own business now
you and your dream are gone
she paid tribute to her son Jihan who
was an actor
I've yet to register jihan's death I
don't think I ever can
please don't forget but remember our
sons and daughters whose lives were
ended on the cold etawan Pavement in
South Korea
49 days on the victim's family say the
government has not been clear in its
words and actions they want to know what
caused the crowd crash on October 29th
and accountability calling for the
minister of the Interior safety is hung
means his step down the presidential
office says it will wait until the
conclusion of police and parliamentary
investigations before deciding who's
responsible more than a dozen people in
the chain of command that night have
been charged with professional
negligence the police investigation is
focusing on why even as the first call
for help went out at 6 34 PM with some
warning of an impending crush it would
take more than four hours to block off
foot traffic from that bottlenecked
Alleyway and as the probes continue and
the deceased are mourned many are still
living with the guilt of having survived
that night one high school student who
survived the crush was found dead in an
apparent suicide late Monday night after
his mother had reported him missing he'd
lost two friends and had been receiving
counseling at school
Eunice Kim Al Jazeera Seoul